hi
uh yeah thank you jen for the intro
as you said my name is antoine butler
and i'm a front-end developer for
an advertising agency outside of dc
called hddg
we build you know websites and apps for
organizations like national football
league volkswagen
and so on and i'm really excited to be
here because i'm on a team
of 14 developers who are primarily
full stack they do really crazy
javascript stuff
node and python development and i'm one
of the few dedicated
front-end developers which makes
something uh like css conf
really awesome so i'd like to say uh
thank you
to to everyone for having me and uh not
doing a uh b track right now instead
so thank you um so until
i'm actually here uh my talk embrace the
vertical
uh the future of media queries um
when i went around to my team i kind of
asked them
if you were here what do you want to
know about vertical media queries and
apologies my uh things slipping here
um and pretty much the consensus was
what are
uh vertical media queries and
i thought you know what that's a really
good question so maybe i'll backtrack
and make sure we're all on the same page
as far as what a
media query is so i apologize if this
is uh a very entry-level introduction to
uh the subject matter um so again what
what is a vertical media query
i'm going to paraphrase the spec because
it's entirely too wordy
uh which reads a media query allows you
to tailor your layout based on any
number of conditions
against a media type and those available
conditions
are of course aspect ratio orientation
resolution color and size and while i'm
here
is to talk to you guys about size
because
it's not just the width that counts um
yeah i had to that's that that gives me
a moment to breathe
so you're part of me if i sound
ridiculously nervous or if i don't
in the amy because this is also my uh
first talk
uh ever so yay
and luckily i think we're kind of
running a little over so
i might be able to make this short and
get everyone to lunch one time
um but i wanted to uh quote chris coyer
um from a article i think two years ago
uh where he said measuring width is a
nice practical example of media queries
but it's not the only thing available
but despite that if you go to any css
gallery you're
littered with websites that are
responsive based
entirely on its width i mean even media
queries
media query.i es have sites
that are responsive almost entirely
based on
their width so to kind of
reiterate what a media query is uh
is this this is what we all typically do
and what we see on the css
um galleries are we running a media
query and we're testing against
a width size a max width or a mid-width
a vertical media query does the
perpendicular i'm just
checking against the height hence the
name embrace the vertical
uh so what why does it matter
it's that's a good question because i
mean if you look we all we all
in this room have done some amazing
things using uh the width as our primary
condition
um but i don't think that's good enough
i think there's opportunities for us to
do some really cool things with our
layout
based on height so one of the reasons
uh that i don't think the width is good
enough and why height is important
is one because content size is variable
not intrinsic
and by content i mean words not images
because of course if we
sell our image to be 100 width and we
make our width more narrow the image
gets smaller
our content our words uh don't scale
all right uh we make our widths and
arrow and the content gets taller
another reason is that we increase the
scrolling which
isn't a bad thing because the fold
doesn't exist
but it is an opportunity for us to
improve upon the user's
scrolling experience another
reason is device fragmentation and by
device i mean any electronic or
mechanical device that we use to
consume web content so not just handheld
tablets
but also the laptops and eventual tvs
that we will
peruse the internet with and
a shameless plug for my wife
who is a rabid fan of wizard of oz
netbooks apples and androids are my
these are the devices that we're talking
about
not just uh the handheld stuff that's in
our pockets right now
also the laptops that are on our desk
and
yeah so question who here remembers this
uh i think it actually originally was
posted around 2010
but they did another article in 2013 to
discuss
device fragmentation um
when this came out i mean there was blog
posts left and right
about how responsive web design was
destined to fail because there was just
too many variables
uh if to me it felt like responsive
fear-mongering it wasn't like we could
just go out and
set all the break points um
so i always hated that graph because it
was it was overwhelming you couldn't
you couldn't really grasp uh what needed
to happen
what i liked better was this graphic
from the same article
which kind of does a better job of
explaining what we do
because it shows the endless amount of
widths
that we all have to deal with doing
responsive web design
but even this only tells half the story
which is why
this graphic is actually my favorite
because it
shows that the height is just as
variable as the width
after all these devices move in both
directions and it doesn't even account
for the fact that we can
change the orientation of our devices
which then
makes our with our height and our height
our width
one of my last
reasons why this is important is because
squishy is not good enough
um unless we're talking dodgeball
because i've watched my kids play and
doesn't matter how soft the ball is um
so to uh quote myself and
take a drink of water
ah delicious um squishy is a legacy
solution
but it is also the foundation of
responsive web design
um basically
a show of hands who has ever done this
not in an email
so this is old school i mean i'm glad it
was a lot of hands because that means
i'm not the only old one here even
though i have less hair than most people
um this this is what we all used to do
to make fluid websites
this was uh what we did before
responsive web design was a thing
um this is pre y2k pre-squishy um
this is when tables were in uh and in
this the same premise of just filling
your your uh
your browsers with is all that
responsive web design um
kind of relies on is as as its core tool
and that's why we're here
to this side with uh this guy with this
accordion which is supposed to be a
metaphor for how
websites like an accordion or squishy uh
horizontally
even though you could hold your
accordion this way and it would still
work
but anyway i wanted to keep him in there
because he looks awesome
and he's happy
anyway my point is that you can only be
squishy in one direction
uh or or reliably in one direction and
that's along the width
so what do we do with that being our
limitation
uh we actually can't be responsive
instead
we have to adapt we'll die trying
um i'm going to paraphrase actually not
perfect i'm going to repurpose a quote
from karen mcgrain
for a list of parts responsive web
design won't fix
your content problem where she said
smart organizations will
see this as a benefit not a drawback and
we use this
chance to make a better website not just
the squishy one
she wasn't talking about vertical media
queries or going back to adaptive design
but the sentiment is true here so
again i want to go back and then
redefine yet again
what exactly a vertical media query is a
vertical media query is not
a responsive tool it is actually an
adaptive solution
to our content design and user
experience problems
so now onto the meat and potatoes of
mattel
uh why everyone is here hopefully is to
see some potentially
cool uh code and this
will be the fun part because it's the
part i haven't practiced so much uh
so here we go uh so first up i wanted to
kind of investigate
a an existing site an existing
opportunity for vertical media queries
and i wanted to make sure i picked a
website where
the developers who involved in it won't
hate me
so i picked wikipedia
uh so the use case is long form reading
um the solutions that wikipedia actually
uh do themselves can be used on blogs
articles
research papers um it's not unique to
wikipedia
anything that has a lot of content this
approach that they do to their uh
to their layouts we all can adapt in
some way
for our for our own purposes so i needed
an article
to use as my example and
since we have a party tonight i figured
i'm going to use my drink of choice
which was bourbon and
yeah find me tonight um
if i make it through this talk so
i searched for work for bourbon whiskey
and the
wikipedia article uh looks something
like that
when you scroll it on your desktop
yep yep okay now we're finished
uh that was fast we didn't read anything
so imagine trying to experience that on
your
mobile device luckily we don't have to
because
wikipedia's own uh mobile page says
users of supported mobile devices are
automatically redirected to the official
mobile version of wikipedia.com
which looks like a much more pleasing
and consumable
that but when i when i
inspected the the
ios simulator i realized two things
uh one the markup was ridiculously
simple
and simple enough that it could actually
serve the desktop
but instead they give us two entirely
different code bases two entirely
different urls
and they redirect so i wanted to compare
the mobile versus desktop
uh solution or ui and essentially all
they did was they simplify the
navigation
they use an accordion layout they center
their images and they change the font to
a more readable
serif all those things we can do without
a separate url and a separate code base
so what i want to do is build a
prototype very bare bones kind of
showcasing a use case for
a vertical media queries but what i'm
going to do is not worry about the
simplified
navigation because well that's just too
much spec work for a day
so here we go uh so what we have here is
a very dumbed down
version of the wikipedia mobile
html which is basically a div with an id
content we've got an h1 for our
article title they've put all their
images
inside of divs class thumb
got an introductory text and h2s
with aria roles that match the id of the
sibling div and that's where their
content is
i didn't want to deal with that so i
converted to something a little more
readable
yay for semantics and we with an article
uh keeping the h1 we're using figures
instead of divs
we got the introductory text
we have an id on our h2 and we're using
sections for
uh the content separation instead of
divs
and uh if anyone wants to actually
follow along from this point uh to see
the more
fleshed out stylized um prototype
just bitly slash wikiproto
all right so i'll give you all five
seconds to not do that
and now we're going to just go to some
base css to kind of get us there
so the first thing i did was again this
is kind of roughly based on the actual
existing
wikipedia.com uh or just set a
font a font weight font size line height
uh sans serif font
we're going to put a border under our
h2s and we're going to float
all our figures to the right and center
the text
there's more in the actual code example
in that url
that you can mess around with but
basically what we end up getting
is a very wikipedia light layout
this is essentially wikipedia i mean
with links and more images
and really robust navigation so
this works now we're going to go and
throw in some some
media queries so the first thing we do
is i'm going to go with an actual
traditional with base media query
first that will essentially just tell
our figure to be full width
and we already have our content centered
uh so if you're on a device that's
650 pixels small small or a browser that
is 650
pixels wide it will center your
your figure elements and then we're
going to use a vertical media query
and all we're really doing is font
family
serif and hiding all the sections and
mind you
uh this display none is exactly what
wikipedia is doing there's no
animations there's no nothing they're
just toggling display none display block
on their div and
it turns this into this
again if you check out the uh the url
you'll see it's
it's that i don't need to do anything
else there's no
redirect there's no nothing so
you throw in some some some image
loading love
slick nav and uh maybe
actual images you you would potentially
render the mobile
version of wikipedia.com unnecessary
so the benefits of an adaptive
wikipedia.com or adaptive
anything really comes down to you don't
have to worry about device detection
which has its own woes
uh you work with a single code base and
sends all of us in here write code
let's coach right the better right and
uh
you get improved seo and shareability
and it's great so wikipedia.com that's
my first
example my next example
is vw.com
so much for picking sites that people
won't be mad at me
but this is actually uh an internal
project as well
so i think it learns a little backstory
so vw.com was recently redesigned and
this is their
their nav we did not design it we didn't
build it or anything like that
um and this this fixed nav on the left
they absolutely love they met all the
requirements of the uh of the clients
the ux everything worked you clicked
more and you got the uh
the navigation slide out off the screen
this is not a
mobile or or tablet approach this is
just desktop
and they liked it so much that when they
came to us
for the properties that we are
responsible for they wanted to reuse
that exact same nav except it had
entirely different requirements and
those requirements
just don't work with what was designed
and approved
so those new requirements were primary
navigation
must support up to six items and if we
actually go back
was too fast ninja
there we go so this is actually full
screen on my 15-inch macbook pro
um i've got enough room for two more
items there but if i'm not full screen
i don't have room for two items and if i
have my uh
my dock exposed i might have room for
one more item
and if i'm on a 13 inch macbook pro i
don't have any more room for anything
so we're talking a desktop experience
that needs to be
adaptive the
second requirement was that the
secondary navigation which is what you
will see when you click on more
i needed to be able to support an
unlimited number of items which means
you can scroll within it because the
navigation can have 10 items and it can
have 100
that's a whole nother design problem but
the third reason and this is actually
something that i added to the
requirements because
i used to do front-end development for
the government so i like to try to make
sure things are as
accessible as possible i wanted
everything to be keyboard
accessible i didn't want to have to rely
on javascript
to to build out my ui or to access
content
so this is what the navigation
on their current site um looks like
when you when it's fully exposed we've
got the
four primary navigation which you'll see
on the right and we've got the list
of secondary navigation which is on the
left
and again if you want to follow along
from this point
with my own prototype please go to
bitly slash sticky nav i'm really
surprised
that wasn't taken already
people are lazy so
again bare bones html this is what i
started off with
nav element on order list i
chose to keep my li for the logo
inside the the list instead of using a
separate header and then all the
additional navigation items
are marked up like so we've got an li
link
an image for the icon and the link text
within a span
now we can handle that image the whole
tons of different ways
um but for my prototype that's the way i
went with it
that's the way it is and like i said
there can be
100 of those if you want and now for my
disclaimer
my following slides of code are using
less not sass because i bet on the dark
horse
so is anyone in here with me
oh and some of you are lying you're
lying lying line line
all right so first thing i did uh
was to kind of easily themify this
uh created a theme variable just so i
can save colors and
if i needed to meddle with them later
for hover states and things
like that the next thing i did was i set
a font size and you'll see that these em
values
go ridiculously long at a point
um but i'm going to put the pixel value
over there as a comment so you know
where what we're working with but
essentially it comes down to
our nav based font size is 11 pixels uh
each individual nav item is 95 pixels by
95
that is a design requirement which also
makes the the button potentially fragile
if the
the text uh get gets too long
and then the exception to our
primary nav size is that the logo height
has to have its own so i'll put that in
a variable
and then we set the drawer width which
is the nav that sits outside of your uh
view to 21.363636
or 235 pixels and
uh the two magic numbers at the bottom
which is which are my favorite because
this actually allows this prototype to
be really flexible
uh since this nav has to exist on
multiple sites with multiple
um requirements one site might say we
only want four
nav items one site might say we want to
have 10. so at any point
you can just change that that highlight
number or even the minimum number
and enforce a new set of rules
on on that nav so up next
we have the nav based styles
and this is why i said i gave up writing
notes so i'm just going to
try to run through each line of css
quickly
but we're going to just transform the uh
the nav i'm going to move it to the left
so that the
the drawer nav the secondary nav is out
of view i'm going to position it fixed
um to the top i'm going to set the width
and some
typography choices here uh so that it
kind of matched what was on vw.com
then sell the actual individual navs the
images and the spans within them
so i'll just go ahead and put the uh
paddings on there
i've got some text uh treatments
uh another transition and
we're gonna position our our image and
spans
uh to be inline so this this is that
secondary nav with the
the text is not a perfect square it's
actually uh
kind of a stacked uh stacked nav single
line
and the css for the ul itself
we set our width we want it to scroll
that way
it can grow forever you can just scroll
within that side pane
and um i chose to use
css content to actually style the
separator between
the secondary nav and the primary and
all that pretty much just gives us this
this is our
default navigation that appears off
screen
uh so that that is our native state with
no other work done
that is all we end up well with and now
for a weird little
uh adjustment to our our uh
our variables for minimum number and
highlight number
in this instance um since i kept the
logo
in the nav when we're counting how many
nav elements we want to have
i have to add one to account for the
logo that's just
deeper into the css no one should be
meddling with that it's kind of like
part of the framework in a way
so next we had to create a uh that all
fits on that good
yeah i had to create a mix end that
basically would stylize
this this native nav to look like a
primary square nav item
and i did so by using display table
which is our
new old friend we positioned it absolute
and we're going to position it off to
the right notice i'm not setting
its top position because we're going to
automate that later
and then i tell the individual links to
display
uh table sale vertical align them in the
middle
um and then just set the padding and
size on them
and now i'm telling my image to be
display blocked so everything looks
like that uh when it gets its
uh the highlight mix and apply to it so
now we actually have to worry about how
to position everything
since we're taking a whole bunch of
stack navigation items on the left
and positioning absolute on the right
and we want to do that in a way that's
not fragile so i wrote a
two mix-ins that will basically do all
the work for me one is called position
uh nav a for readability
that essentially just counts the number
of
items that we want to be primary and
calculates how far from the top they
should be which is easy to do because we
already know how tall the nav
height is when the logo height is and
how tall each individual nav item is
so when we apply that to say position
six
items we get a top position for all six
um they know exactly where they need to
be
nice and the uh the the mix in itself
does all the work for us
and the last is a mix in to position
the more button because the more button
now needs to know
where all the nav items above it are and
how many nav items are actually visible
uh so now uh this is just kind of like a
base
uh well not really base this is kind of
a
the css to kind of kick-start everything
so we're going to take our first
ally that we know is our logo we're
going to set the height on it
we're going to uh call the mix in
highlight so we're telling it to
be 95 pixels wide to go absolute to go
to the right and our exception here is
that we're telling it how tall it needs
to be
and then the other exception is that the
image actually needs to fill the
container not be this tiny little icon
and the uh next line is based on our
minimum offset
we need to make sure we stylize the
minimum amount of
uh primary nav items that we want in
this case it's three
that's what gets passed to the mix-in so
we tell the first three nav items
after the logo to be stylized and move
to the right
uh and now we kickstart the uh the
position
magic where we're saying all right as of
the
second one start positioning all the nav
items
and now for the fun part where i had to
pull back my
middle school math and
reverse engineer the em value
for for the body essentially i'm just
trying to get back to the
root em uh i don't even know if i wanna
walk through this but
it's in there so i figured i should show
it um but i'm essentially just figuring
out the first fraction
uh for um how much how tall
the nav is accounting for all the items
that we want to show
and putting that against the font size
and then giving me the em back to
what our what our body is instead of the
actual nav the nav thinks
everything is based off of 11px but my
media query is going to be based off of
the the body which is uh typically the
browser default of 16 pixels
and then in that same media query uh we
are going to
um at this point decide
when there's no longer enough room for
the nav items
to remove them from the primary section
and let them go back into their uh their
native uh position
off the screen uh and essentially i'm
just saying you know
uh using an child uh saying
show the first four if there's no space
so the first five there's enough space
and in order to do that i'm actually
counting backwards in my add media query
instead of
typically adding one um and
another thing worth noting is that i
actually had to position the
more button based on the max height and
we're doing the opposite
for the individual primary items where
we're doing it on a minimum height so if
there's at least this one
enough room for four show four if
there's enough room for five
show five and here
is a video that i think will play easily
showing the nav in action
and yeah
um so yeah that's
that's my my best use case actually for
uh
for for vertical media coils right now
and as you saw it's not a responsive
solution it's not squishy
um we were originally going to go with
this squishy solution because
it's the easy solution in this instance
we could just make the more button fixed
to the bottom
and then tell the client that no it's
really cool actually you can scroll
within this 95 pixel
wide container which would have worked
but the experience wouldn't have been
great
so now instead we have a perfectly
flexible uh component that can live on
any vw property
based on a really simple set of rules
and it's my best use case right there
so what else can we do uh just some
ideas
because really what i wanted to do in
this talk is kind of motivate
other people to start thinking about the
height
it's easy to overlook it let's stop
um so other options are single page
navigations
galleries uh you know you have uh
captions that sit on top of your image
uh based on your your screen size you
might not have room for that that text
anymore
uh what are you gonna do with it you
just hide it and say oh no you know
mobile no one wants to read the caption
no we could probably do some really
interesting things figure it out um
scrolling sites and and takeovers
those kind of in-page interstitial ads
or messages
that are very subject to limited height
because typically
we designed them to hold 100 words
and the client puts in a thousand so
that's that that's that's my argument
for uh
vertical media queries and i don't know
how long that was
i'm hoping it was like 20 20 minutes so
i thought
uh and that's that thank you